I know this if you're willing to listen
to be guided by that still small voice
that is the GPS within yourself to find
out what makes you come alive you will
be more than okay you will be happy you
will be successful and you will make a
difference in the world
virgins fireman speech to Harvard
graduates in 2013 almost didn't happen
because she was scared over what we
scared I was like she had nothing new to
teach them she reflects on this moment
in her new book the path made clear
discovering your life's direction and
purpose
Oprah reveals the many lessons she has
learned including how to fight for your
head on she explains how you you you you
hold the power to discover your purpose
and live your greatest truth I know I
was listening to the speech and I said
were they playing music there but we did
we did but over this is the thing I want
to talk about the Harvard speech because
I remember that day very well
brown nervous you were yeah and I don't
know nervous with speeches as you know
no I know well if that but first we got
to talk about Prince Harry because this
news just broke this morning about you
and Prince Harry teaming up to work on
work with Apple yes it just broke this
morning we're glad about that yeah but
Harry says this I'm incredibly proud to
be working alongside Oprah on this vital
series how did you in Harry get known as
H to his friends get together well I was
having a conversation with him about I
actually asked the question what do you
think are the most important issues
facing the world right now and he said
there are two he said climate change and
he said mental wellness mental fitness
is one to wellness mental fitness and
the mental health and it as you know
he's spoken about his own issues and
what he went through after his mother
died and how being able to talk about it
has benefited him so and so it's a
passion of his and I think the view to
get the end of the conversation he said
and I said you know I'm gonna be doing
this thing with Apple I'm going I'm yeah
I said it's a bit
of mine - and I want to try to erase the
stigma and I was telling him about what
this Apple platform and he said at the
end of the conversation oh if there's
anything I can do to help and I got you
know what you're gonna do at this point
yes we're doing a multi-part docu-series
on mental health all of its and the
spectrum and what's Harry's involvement
going to be and Harry is co-creating
this with me and he is executive
producing this because lots of ideas had
several meetings I've had secret
meetings in London I'd flown there with
the crew sitting in sessions talking
about you know the directions we're
gonna take I think it's going to make a
our hope is that it will have an impact
on reducing the stigma and allowing
people to know that they're not alone
and allowing people to speak up about it
and being able to identify it for
themselves and and their friends you
know yeah we need that spiritual
guidance yes and if someone who knows
megan merkel how do you think she is
being portrayed I think she's being
portrayed unfairly and I feel that if
people really knew her they would know
that she is not only everything that we
perceive her her perceive of her as
being graceful and dynamic and holding
that position but she just has a
wonderful warm giving loving heart so I
mean I see all the crazy press around
her and I think it's really unfair it
was very kind she doesn't seem to buy
into it though which I think if she
actually does not read anything like
that which I find you know you know I
think that's remarkable that in spite of
all that's going on she does not read
anything she's living her life she's
living a very good live baby
countdown is underway but this is a
great thing about this book number one
Oprah I'm not just saying that this
because I know you even love you so much
the book is really good I read it
yesterday I'm sitting the bed left I
walked in this morning she got the book
is really good I was a bank yesterday
and while I was waiting for the business
to happen I'm reading to my banker
Germaine and said if you're at a
crossroads in your career or a
relationship if you're struggling with
fine
with addiction or take control of your
health the journey to lasting change
begins with defining what matters most
to you he goes could you take a picture
of that and send it to me my fiancee
Chanel because she is struggling with
this very thing right now yeah he goes
who wrote that I go over he goes Oprah
writes so anyway so what is a question
to this I thought it was really very
powerful it all begins with you you have
to define what matters to you most yeah
the most important question anybody can
ever ask themselves is what do I really
want and I used to do this at the end of
the show when I was talking to the
audience which was just my favorite part
of every show and I have people set up
and tell me what do you really want and
the truth is most people could not
answer that question a lot of women
always say I just want to be happy or
one way my games why can't we answer
that question because you haven't really
given it the thought that it deserves
and everything flows from that question
of what do I want what's so interesting
in this book and all the people that you
talk to in a lot of cases it took
somebody on the outside to say to them
you're this yes yes but everybody has it
within them you know that's why I think
it's when I was writing this I was
thinking this is such a great graduation
gift and I'm gonna give it to all my
girls of graduating actually I'm doing
my last graduation I don't intend to go
to another graduation after this year
that's currently I don't because I have
xx girl graduating I've been to 20
graduations in the past three years and
I am done okay but I want to give this
book graduations because I think so many
kids are coming out of school and they
don't know which direction to take a lot
of people are in their lives their 30s
or 40s and they still don't know what
their purpose is you know but I think
it's interesting about graduations
because everybody wants you to be the
graduation speaker and when the Harvard
request came in that actually kind of
threw you which surprised me because
you've done many graduations yes I've
taught in school I've been speaking so
Harvard Harvard name and that's why I
opened the speech saying I'm ed because
that sort of released a lot of the
attention and the intimidation I was
feeling because I thought wow
Harvard these are really really but it
came
I'm in your life and it came at a time
in my life when you're vulnerable yes
when I felt vulnerable and every single
headline was about Oprah and the
struggling Network so I was like what
could I possibly say to them when I'm in
the midst of the struggle which actually
have more to say when you're in the
midst of the struggle then you do right
and I went back and reread this speech
and you said there is no such thing as
failure failure is just life trying to
move us in another direction well it
certainly looks like failure at the time
but if you learned this from Maya if you
in the midst of the failure my would say
say thank you say thank you which is
hard to do you say thank you because you
know that there is a clearing a path
that will be made on the other side of
that that allows you to use that failure
as information and I always say this to
everybody particularly students that
knowing what you don't want to do is
equally as important as knowing what you
do want to go true because when you try
something and it doesn't work it's not a
failure it's information that whoa I'm
in the wrong place I'm in the wrong job
and just before I was demoted in my my
job early in my career I mean that was
big if that had not happened to me I
would not have become what I became in
in in in my work because we might not
have been friends we might well we were
all where do you were friends kill I
know but but if you hadn't been demoted
to really talk it through
yes you might not have been the fans we
are because that's where we met in the
bathroom
yeah don't meet me in the bathroom we're
squeezing in a break there is